- After watching Scandal
and West Wing and shit,
you don't know what's going on.
So there could be like a
secret, secret, secret service
that we don't know about.
(intense music)
- Well, I did really well in school.
I'm a good test taker.
I'm really good at math and science.
But I'm shit at history.
- I took college prep English classes all
throughout high school,
I'm a very good writer,
very strong with that, good
at history, horrible at math,
horrible at science.
- I got a perfect score
on the ACT in reading.
And did pretty well in science,
but I did horrific in math.
- I do like logic puzzles.
I used to do them when I was a kid.
And I do like to do the
Sunday crossword puzzle.
- I imagine, to be a part
of the secret service,
you have to be incredibly smart.
I don't think they put
the life of the president
in just anybody's hands.
- The scary part is that they
know a lot more information
than we know and they're always watching.
- I feel like this test
is gonna be really hard.
This practice test section
contains six passages, each
of which describe a set of facts.
Each passage is followed
by three test questions
that are conclusions based
on the set of facts presented
in the passage.
You will read the passage
and then decide whether
each conclusion is true, false,
or if there is insufficient
information to decide.
This section contains 18 questions
and you will have 30
minutes to complete it.
- [Voiceover] Melinda is a
secret service special agent.
Susan has never been to Georgia.
All secret service special
agents have been to Georgia.
Fred works with Susan.
Susan is a secret service special agent.
- Susan is a secret service
special agent is false
because it says Susan has
never been to Georgia,
and all secret service special
agents have been to Georgia.
- Oh yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's totally, yeah.
- Fred works for the secret service.
If Fred works with Susan, we
know that Susan doesn't work
for the secret service, so
then Fred wouldn't be able
to work for the secret service.
Regardless of whether or
not he's been to Georgia.
So, he does not work for, it's false.
- Insufficient information to
decide because I don't know
if people in the secret service
work with people who aren't
in the secret service.
- Fuck!
(laughing)
- Passage three, all
task force agents work
from either Boston or Chicago.
Some Boston Task Force agents
are financial fraud investigators.
All Chicago task force agents
All Boston task force agents who
are financial fraud investigators
receive financial investigation training.
No Chicago task force agents
received financial investigation training.
All Chicago task force agents
received cyber security training.
- No task force agents who
received cyber security training
are financial fraud investigators.
- All these broad statements.
Some, all.
- That's the point.
- Fuck that, be direct.
That's what life is about.
- No one in Chicago is a
financial fraud investigator.
But we know that all Chicago
task force agents are financial
fraud, so I'm gonna say false.
- Insufficient information to decide.
I'm just gonna go with it.
- All Chicago task force agents
are financial fraud investigators
and all Chicago task force agents receive
cyber security training.
Therefore, there are financial
fraud investigators who
receive cyber security training.
Therefore making the statement false.
Yes.
- [Voiceover] Statement two,
no task force agents who
received financial investigation
training work from Chicago.
- The people in Boston get
the financial investigation training and
the people in Chicago get
the cyber security training.
So it makes it true.
- No one from Chicago receives
financial investigation
training, so it is true.
- I concur.
(laughing)
No Chicago task force agents
receive financial investigation training.
I started to get nervous.
Like, what if they moved.
(upbeat music)
I wanted a perfect score
but I over thought it
and died on the last one so.
- I don't feel bad that I
did bad, because I mean maybe
that means I should like,
you know, tap into that side
of my brain more.
Maybe this is like room for improvement.
I mean, it's some bullshit,
but it's room for improvement.
- I just feel like, with
these kind of tests,
you constantly like second guess yourself
and you don't really know.
So it might be a test of like,
how much are you confident
with your gut instinct
and I think a couple times
it showed that I wasn't.
- It's not that hard to
figure out the answers.
And I got a 94%, which is an
A, so, I'm like, you know,
pretty happy.
- They should do this
test while on the range.
And there's like targets
popping up, false, true.
(uplifting music)